CONFIRMATION ASIDE, G.O.P. SEES
AN OPENING WITH BLACK VOTERS.
WHAT AN ODD SENTENCE.
ONE PROFESSIONAL CANDIDATE
QUOTED IN THE PIECE, JENNIFER
GREENE JOINS US NOW.
JENNIFER, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT WAS
SAID IN "THE ANGLE" TONIGHT
ABOUT DEMOCRATS BELIEVING THAT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS APPARENTLY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO GET
VOTER I.D. AT THE SAME LEVEL AS
OTHERS.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT FIRST OFF.
>> WOW.
IN THIS COUNTRY, WE NEED IDEAS
FOR LITERALLY EVERYTHING, AND
THAT'S HONESTLY INSULTING TO SAY
THAT BLACK AMERICANS CAN'T GET
IDEAS COME OUT WON'T GET THEM,
AND IT'S JUST A TROJAN HORSE AND
ANOTHER HAT TRICK TO CONTINUE TO
POLITICIZE RACE THAT WE
CONSISTENTLY SEE FROM THE TOP
AND THE ELITES AND THE DEMOCRATS
CONSISTENTLY STRIVING TO USE
RACE TO PANDER.
THERE ARE NOT FOCUSED ON THE
CLEAR THEMES OF AN ELECTION
INTEGRITY, THEY ARE FOCUSED ON
GETTING DEMOCRATS ELECTED AND
THAT SHAMEFUL.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
AMERICANS TONIGHT WATCHING AND
WHAT DO THEY NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
CHANGES IN THE ELECTORATE?
ESPECIALLY DEMOCRATS AS
NEWT GINGRICH SAID IT.
THEY TRIED TO PAINT THIS PICTURE
AS REPUBLICANS OR INDEPENDENTS
AS PRO PUTIN.
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
THEY ARE PRO PUTIN, OR PUTIN,
BLAMING FOX, NEVER LOOKING IN
THE MIRROR.
WHAT DO AMERICANS NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE CHANGING BLACK VOTING
LANDSCAPE?
>> BLACK PEOPLE,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, WE ARE NOT A
MONOLITH.
RIGHT?
YOU JUST CAN'T CONTINUE TO
CONCEPTUALIZE US AS A SINGLE
FACTOR.
WE ARE NOT STUPID.
AND WE SEE THE CLARITY OF ALL OF
THE FAILURES THAT CONTINUE TO
EXIST.
WE SEE THE CRAZY SKYROCKETING OF
PRICES.
WE SEE THE ENERGY COSTS
CONTINUING WE CONTINUING TO PAY
FOR.
WE SEE THE POOR INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS.
THAT'S CONTINUOUS.
BLACK VOTERS ARE NOT STUPID, AND
IF WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS JUST IN
GENERAL ABOUT SEEING HOW 18
MONTHS AGO WE WERE BETTER OFF AS
A COUNTRY, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE BLACK VOTERS
REENGAGE AND SEE AND FOCUS ON
THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING FROM AN OLD FRIEND OF
YOURS, AL SHARPTON.
THIS IS HOW HE SAID HOW THE
DEMOCRATS NEED TO TO GET THE
MESSAGE OUT TO BLACK VOTERS.
>> DID NOT GET GEORGE FLOYD
JUSTICE BILL IF PASSED, BUT WHAT
DID WE DO?
BIDEN PUT MORE BLACKS ON THE
FEDERAL COURTS THAN ALL
PRESIDENTS COMBINED.
NOBODY KNOWS THAT.
YOU'VE GOT TO PUT YOUR MESSAGE
OUT THERE.
WHAT WE'VE DONE, WHY IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE, WHEN IT MEANS TO
YIELD, NOT THE WASHINGTON
BELTWAY CROWD.
>> Laura: JENNIFER, IS THAT
THE RIGHT MESSAGE FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN VOTERS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE FOCUS HAS TO BE ON WE KEPT
OUR PROMISES, DID WHAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO AND AMERICA'S
BETTER FOR I.
100%, PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
DEMOCRATS IN THE LIBERAL ELITE
CANNOT SAY THAT.
NANCY PELOSI, PRESIDENT BIDEN,
THEY'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE.
THE EXTENSIVE FAILURES IN THE
CLEAR LACK OF VISION FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
AND THEY CANNOT GET AWAY FROM
BEING THE SCAPEGOATS THAT THEY
ARE FOR THE DECISIONS THAT
THEY'VE MADE, AND THE APPROACH
WILL NOT WORK.
OF BLACK VOTERS ARE NOT IGNORANT
TO THE REALITIES OF THE
SITUATION WE FACE AMERICA.
>> Laura: HIGH GAS PRICES,
FOOD PRICES, ARE YOU BETTER OFF
THAN YOU WERE THREE YEARS
AGO, -- YOU'RE GOING TO SAY NO.
THAT'S A SIM